[Musik]
Online cov mobile soziale Telefonie ist
Eingeborener und das in diesem Monat von Techniken
d'ast higuita die sterne revolutionieren nicht
nichts Milliardus Nick Adams Place oder
souls easy ist aber novare links
wir brauchten pauline piece training
diskret ein Film sein Dreh ist
dann fiel der feine schnee von aslan liegt auf
salagou mental oder digital und
im Rahmen des Zumutbaren
[Musik]
dieses produkt zu heiligen priester ein kleines
Vertrag demonstriert Fanette Kostüm
Steuern Ende des ungeschickteren kleinen Würfels
gestern
Torrentfreak 4s zu emotionales Weihnachten in
Flasche Ketchup führt zu Mobilität
Fatah und Handschuhe ein Eis inklusive 7 6 8
6 und Materialist, der diktieren wird
iranische revolution bruce willis
andere Körper bleiben im Dunkeln
Endlich ist der Deal heute
wird für alles verwendet, wofür es verwendet werden kann
da es zur Verbesserung verwendet werden kann
andere Waren und Dienstleistungen das Geschäft ist
wird eigentlich von allen genutzt
Unternehmen und die Bewegung und geht mehr
früh und recht deutlich in Richtung a
drastische Erhöhung der Mittelbeschaffung
insbesondere im Zusammenhang mit Dip-Lernen
der künstlichen Intelligenz, von der wir
weiß, das sind Geräte, die sind
sehr datenintensiv, dass brauchen
gefüttert werden mit Geben zu machen
die bestmögliche Service-Strenge
hennebicq tate generiert erworben bei
Himmelsteam
3-Milliarden-Dollar-Note Lisa ist reif und bei
denman pussy spyshot einmal
Low-Key beinhaltet Fußball und
petite france bestätigt dina des thalys oder
der Berg der Film, der Ihre Rente bringt
gerichtlicher Konkurs der eingestellten Inhalte
in 10 Jahren unser arabisches Antiquitäten-Netzwerk
ist der Meinung, nein
[Musik]
Militärbanktitel Freitauchen
Magazin aktu die diktatur aber zu
die ankunft in vaumas nam a frieden ist leer
und oslo in zehn filmen aus daxlandes und
Charles Daney und Dreier-Bounce-Logo
davon kein schlimmstes Unglück dieses 19
Yamgnane-Wahn
jedoch eine gewisse Reinheit von
Index-Rechenzentren sagte Eule
außer wie in belfast geholfen
attraktiv 1914 und Attraktivität von
Clasicos stehen vor einem Prozess
Stabilität und nicht bettlägerig zu sein reißen
Cunsky finde ich Drachen gegenüber
Wer dem Nautilud gegenübersteht, ist Emission
Konto der guten Café-Musik mit
eine hochtechnische Ausbildung absolvieren
spezialisiert
Wir haben ein bisschen das Aufkommen eines Doppelten
Rede
einerseits ein digitaler Tresor a
Art von National 4.0 reduziert, was wäre
sehr datenschutz- und
zugleich ein rechtlicher Rahmen, der
die realität ist jetzt genug
mangelhaft und die Bastille ist dazu ermächtigt
Bargeld ist gesundes Blatt mehr Glam
und füttert ait und alice dautry banken
stimmen Sie zu, dass Camara eindeutig gewesen ist
wählen sie die herkunft nachrichten redaktion uns
wird von asti schweiz anwalt [ __ ] übergeben
auch das attraktive Ministerjahr
warum eine Ermüdung zu Fuß zu warten
9 Uhr Tel Angie gezähmt werden, was Samsung
Chefmodell der Stif und das schockiert nicht
nicht unwiderstehlich honda toyota und ali ben
romdhane eine Depression müde in dhr
und Signalhorn qu aqmi tyson Homosexuell gutes Hündchen
und Mick McCarthy von Acts Europe und Chez
gewerkschaft licht in datum französisch offen in der
blinde lange Eckzähne und oder Blog a
Schätzungen zufolge musste eine Seifenoper gesenkt werden
Institut hält ainis für sehr attraktiv
foto philippe renault stadion im
zurück Ich blieb und es wird immer schlimmer
Chirico Müsli-Apps
[Musik]
oder wissen das heute schon
einige unserer Unternehmen, die sind
in Europa aktiv sind und wollen
Verträge abschließen mit
Europäische Partner sehen einige
Märkte entgehen ihnen, weil wir
Hat nicht geholfen, sie zu befreien
Datenschutz auf gleichem Niveau
als die, die wir in der Gewerkschaft kennen
europäisch
[Musik]
in
Anne of Illegal eine tolle Szene von
Katharina von Aragon und schneller und wer
ist beides wie eine Sharon-Theorie
tate und wir brauchen die Daten zu sein
gespeichert sind unverletzlich, weil sie
sind durch eine Betoneinfassung geschützt
schließlich gibt es eine ganze Reihe von zwei
Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf ihre Daten
rechtlichen Weg oder nicht in gewisser Weise endgültig
aus Drittstaaten
[Musik]
Val d'isere erleichtert dreißig Jahren
verbrachte in Badminton dieser Abteilung
fatah y des gongs wünscht einen schönen
Mit militärischer Finesse löschte er alle Flecken
von Nielsen von Alice Lost and Moved
Gruppengröße der Vorzeigeabteilung
Punk-Grunge, um explosiven Frag zu attestieren
anonym am 21. august in cannes für zwei
Ordner
die schweiz hat keine klare strategie
gerahmt aufbewahren und schützen
Daten
Sie argumentierte, das Land habe es immer noch nicht getan
verstehen den Wert der Informationen, die wir
werden da wieder so angegeben
Technologie, aber nicht wie etwas
das ist der Wert
zusätzlich zu unserer mangelhaften Gesetzgebung auf
Informationssicherheit ermöglicht
Ausland Zugang zu haben
potenziell sensible Daten wir
Lassen Sie uns unsere Server leeren
Souveränität der Schweiz, die in verlässt
Lutscher
awa gibt es eine Form von Rassismus um 14 Uhr fest
Die afghanische Reggae-Roots-Band Take One ist
Dies ist ein gesunder Weg wie Swisscom
blindenschrift hartenstein am dienstag zu verurteilt
Belley ain el far Pfirsich Olazabal und
die abwartende haltung nimmt zu und die me-abteilung
Fatah und Gongs Nightmare ist passend
entweder die stran am schweiz wirft a
schreckliche Verzögerung gegenüber der Gewerkschaft
Europäisch diese globale Bremse, von der es kommt
die allgemeine Unfähigkeit, das zu verstehen
neue digitale Welt verändert sich
Sozialgesetzbücher Wirtschaft Sicherheit
Konsistenz zu gewährleisten und
Zusammenhalt des Systems Schweiz muss
Diskutieren Sie diesen Bereich
das gespräch hat nicht bestanden bejahen
bayrou a like swisscom ventures
physisch real unsere Infrastrukturen
muss cybersicher sein
Die Schweiz braucht einen Kapitän
jede Menge Cyberspace, den wir alle haben
die notwendigen Ressourcen, aber niemand
um uns den Norden zu zeigen
[Musik]
links ist zufrieden, weil sie dumm ist
Wütend ganz rot ist eine Einheit
Kanadier müssen die Kosten tragen
Produktion zwischen Zionisten lohnt sich a
Pizza-Date, denke ich, ist fähig
Am Ende denke ich, dass dies die Basis ist
die zur gegebenen Zeit aufwachen müssen
dass es dauern wird, was eine Bewegung ist
Bürger wer wer wer aufbricht
verlangen digitale Gesamtzustände
in der schweiz findet das geschäftsproblem statt
Lester war keine gute Seifenoper
annabac ansonsten eine diktierte Aussage
die Faux-Suspense-Wagen-Aktivität 10:15 Uhr
debatte und nicht technisch und steve parr
ist verbreitet
[Musik]
und